[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
theoretical physicist and a professor at
the school of Earth and space
exploration at Arizona State University
Lawrence Krauss welcome to the Reuben
report it's great to be here you are in
the middle of like 8,000 things and
we're gonna have to use some theoretical
physics in the time space-time continuum
8,000 plus or minus a million yeah yeah
plus or minus a million all right well
I'm very excited to talk to you I think
I publicly shamed you into doing this
several times every reason really yeah
well it's hard to publicly shame me but
you did try yeah yeah you did yeah and
and but I wanted to do it it's just a
matter of fitting in and it's great that
we can be here today
yeah all right so I'm very excited
you're heading to UCLA to do some more
talk after this but let's let's jump
right into the election okay because I
have to yeah maybe we'll talk about the
science no you know why not as a man of
science
uh-huh how do you feel about just the
tenor of this and and not just the tenor
but as someone that cares about
empirical evidence they don't care about
facts how do you feel about just the
state of what is going on right now it's
every every year I always wonder if it
could be worse because you know let's
face it politics and empirical evidence
don't go together very well as a rule
and know for a long time I've been
interested in trying to make sure public
policy is based on that and in a lot of
different ways in my writing and we we
actually created a group in 2008 called
science debate which would we tried to
get a presidential debate on issues of
science and technology not to ask them
the tenth digit of pi but I mean if you
the issues that really matter
yeah that are going to affect the future
for people are not the issues that ever
talked about their energy the
environment security all of that depends
on on an understanding of Science and
Technology Policy and so it's always
been ignored and we and we've been
frustrated by but but I have to say that
this is this year of course with Donald
Trump takes the cake in so many ways
he's the I wrote a piece in The New
Yorker which more or less called him the
anti science candidate if such you think
is possible the only person I think on
the Republican slate that was more anti
science remarkably was Ben Carson
right let's just talk about Carson yeah
yeah no I want because it's yeah why not
because he's such a fool how can you be
he's an he's a
neurosurgeon neurosurgeon right how can
you be a neurosurgeon and against so
many of the things that a scientist has
to believe in well not just against
ignorant about them that that's what
amazed me it's it's it's it's one thing
to be I logic ideologically opposed but
he would talk about evolution away which
clearly never didn't understand
evolution which is the basis of biology
besides calling the big bang hoax from
the devil and all I mean just well
that's yeah yeah exactly you know that
and the fact we didn't land in the moon
but uh but so what it demonstrates is
and it's unfortunate but actually it's
relevant my mother wanted me to be a
doctor and and and she made the mistake
of sort of getting me interested in
science and and and want to be a
scientist and then I discovered when I
was in high school that doctors weren't
scientists I apologize to all doctors
they're not and and he's a perfect
example you to be to be a good dot and
that and that's not to say I mean many
doctors trying to keep up with science
obviously sure but to be a good
neurosurgeon requires eye hand
coordination and know and an
understanding of what to what to do when
you open up a brain it's I will get in
trouble for saying this but it's a very
sophisticated kind of car mechanic and
so he clearly was very good at those
technical things but obviously you don't
obviously he not only did not know much
science but he he willfully and this is
the real problem with with religion with
someone like him he decides what's right
based on the Scriptures and anything
disagrees with it must be wrong and
that's that's the real difference
between religion and science were in
religion you know the answers before you
ask the questions and in science we try
and ask the questions and find out the
answers and they may surprise us yeah
and they may change over the course of
not only may they often do and the
willingness to say you're wrong or to
change your mind it's profoundly
importance in science which brings us
back to Donald Trump but but real quick
just a bit Carson began it's such an
interesting example of this I'm glad you
made the distinction of saying that he's
a neurosurgeon non-scientists yeah now
fumbled it twice it's all because a
neuroscientist has to really have the
scientific knowledge the way you're
describing the you know a souped-up car
guy
a car mechanic it's like really he's
doing he's doing a physical act he's
repairing damage and and he needs to
know how to do that it you know I again
one doesn't want to generalize for all
neurosurgeons based on Ben Carson but it
demonstrates that there's a difference
yeah and he and I'm assuming he was good
at what he did and it wasn't all hype
I'm willing to grant him that but in
everything else he says he expressed
more ignorance not just antagonism but
ignorant about fundamental science than
any other candidate in the Republican
Party which says a lot because because
there you know there it has
unfortunately become the anti science
party of late and it wasn't always that
way their party's been a big supporter
of science over the years right now
because they insist on denying the
existence of climate change and many on
the right insist on denying the
existence of evolution or even the big
bang and their their attitudes towards
homosexuality they have necessity by
ideology been forced to confront the
evidence of science and ignore it or or
disregard it or or or lie about it right
so basically they've staked out a
position based on non fact and then that
sort of boxes them in there are real
problem what do you do when when you're
wrong and you can't afford to say wrong
and the problem actually the real
problem with politics is people are not
willing to say you know what we had this
policy but it was wrong we've changed
our minds because it and and I really
the public one of the reasons I want to
have wanted to insert more science into
into public policy is not not the
knowledge of science but the process of
science which is based on empirical
evidence and testing and and and
evolving your views and if we really
want to have sound public policy we
can't we can't just be willing to say oh
well someone was wrong once and
therefore you know we're not gonna
listen to them stating you're that we
were wrong and explaining why is to me
raises you to a higher level it's a bit
of somebody it's a beautiful thing in
fact as a scientist often say as a
theoretical physicist I say the two
greatest states to be in our being wrong
or confused because that means a lot
more to learn yeah there's a little room
there
for a lot of rooms I mean I mean it's
really learning is a process of
discovering errors and what you were
thinking and and I have often I've said
in fact my new book I said somewhere
that that science one of the purposes of
science is to to make people
uncomfortable and and I don't mean that
in a bad sense but if we're always
comfortable it means we're never going
outside our comfort zone it means our
myopic views are never being questioned
or confronted and that's what living is
all about that's what mute music art
literature are all about I mean it's you
know I'll bring in happens to be today
I'm excited because Bob Dylan just won
the Nobel Prize you know but but you
know people like Bob don't force us to
confront I remember when I was young our
views about ways society worked and
science should be the same way and and
good politicians should be should be all
about that it's amazing to me when I've
been in in some other countries and and
and and confronting presidents or prime
ministers who actually I actually know
something yeah and then I'm you know
that's not to say I mean Obama's a yeah
anyway I don't want to yeah well we all
no matter what yeah we can you're gonna
get hey wait till you see what happens
on Twitter but but we can talk about
Obama in Clinton but interestingly it
sounds like you're saying you don't
necessarily care if the if the president
knows that much about tides but you at
least want them to be intellectually
curious enough to assign the right
people exactly look the president can't
be an expert in everything yeah but the
president needs to know they're not if
the first thing is to know you're not an
expert in everything which Donald Trump
hasn't yet figured out right and
secondly to be intellectually curious
and thirdly to choose the right people
that's really what you want a president
to do is have good advisors is to know
enough to distinguish people who are
full of garbage I'll use that word and
and and and people you could trust whose
opinions you could trust because you
know that they're willing to be wrong
too
and so I think that's a really the mark
would president and in in in the current
climate you obviously can't be an expert
in anything and an amazing me when we
talk about you know having debate on
science they say well the president
should be a scientist but you know you
know we have a
debate on national security but with the
president doesn't have to be a military
expert he has to surrounded himself or
herself with with reasonable people who
know what's going on or on diplomacy so
is the intellectual curiosity part of it
is that the part that about Trump gets
you the most
well it's intellectual curiosity and
skepticism and skepticism is a key part
of science be asking yourself is this
evidence reasonable and why should I
believe that yeah that the thing that
it's hard to know what yeah and Trump is
such an anomaly but the fact that when
he says you know who do you take advice
from he says for myself because I'm you
know I know that our Matt when when
someone says that no matter what they're
running for whether it's President or or
or head of a school board or whatever
you should worry about that and and so I
think it's that and his incredible anger
and vindictiveness and you know people
have called him a a bully but you know I
did I did a dialogue with it with a
Hollywood friend of mine named Johnny
Depp and he and he point out that wasn't
who he actually he actually played
Donald Trump in it you should watch it
on Netflix he's a great show where he he
looks just like him it's great but he
said that don't Trump isn't a bully he's
a brat and that that defines the man to
me he's not a bully so much it's just a
spoiled brat who if he's losing finds a
reason to blame other people it again
he's the center of his own universe and
all of that is is is is terrifying and
an ignorant in the extreme I mean one of
when I wrote about science and and the
candidates this year this year one of
the statements that Trump made that just
to me epitomizes the level of ignorance
of the man because first of all a lot of
what he says is just meant he doesn't
care whether it's true or not he thinks
it'll play well or not that I can
understand that's power when you say you
know why are we worried about the ozone
why can't I have you know aerosols in my
hairspray because I only use my
hairspray indoors so it can't affect I
can't the fact that one really said that
now that's the kind of thing you say oh
my goodness gracious
you
[Music]